as i mentioned in the monologue life can
be very boring
you forgot the monologue
luckily every one of us this is fun
everyone has a safe inside of us that is
filled with joy and i really believe
this you just have to find ways to
unlock that safe it's always there for
you so this is my pleasure to present
one of those techniques in a segment we
call unlocking the joy safe
yeah
that got me halfway there just the intro
graphic everything's okay
so listen going to the doctor can be
awkward it can be anxious and in my
opinion way too serious especially the
urologist that's the yep
that's uh the pp doctor
because i'm a grown man that's what i
call the pp doctor here take a look at a
typical visit to the
doctor well mr mccarthy everything seems
to check out with your penis and the
rest of your genitals
thank you doctor
and what are your credentials
i have a phd in urology
yep
boring
snooze
you got to inject a little humor in
there lighten the mood your it's your
insurance have some fun wouldn't this be
so much better
well mr mccarthy everything seems to
check out with your penis and the rest
of your genitals
thank you doctor and what are your
credentials
i have a phd in urology a phd
more like ph
i'm sorry if saying phd's nuts doesn't
unlock the safe where you keep your joy
i can't help you